اذا هي عمليه عسكريه في قطاع غزه فجر هذا
اليوم وفقا لبيان الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا
التخطيط لهذه العمليه يوم الثلاثاء الماضي
استهدفت هذه العمليه قاده في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ومعامل للتصنيع العسكري التابعه
للحركه وفقا للبيان الاسرائيلي ايضا شاركت
فيها نحو 40 طائره مقاتله قصفت هذه
الطائرات عده مناطق في قطاع غزه لاسيما في
الشجاعيه في خان يونس وفي الرفح هنا كما
نشاهد عقب العمليه فورا شهدت مناطق غلاف
غزه استنفارا امنيا كبيرا السلطات
الاسرائيليه فتحت الملاجئ في كل من سبيروت
عسقلان اسدود وحتى في جنوب تل ابيب عموم
مناطق تالغزه في بئر السحر السبع ايضا
تعمل سلطات الاحتلال على اجلاء نحو اربعه
الاف وخمسم شخص من سكان زيروت كما تلاحظون
المتاخمه هنا لحدود قطاع غزه مراسل
الجزيره افاد بان حافلات عده تنقل مجندات
اسرائيليات شوهدت هنا في قاعده زكيم هنا
حيث تشاهدون هذه القاعده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وقد استهدفت هذه القاعده فيما
مضى لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي قال ان مغادره
المجندات من القاعده هدفه المساعده في
عمليات الانقاذ لكن في الوقت نفسه اعلن
الجيش عن توفير ملاجئ متنقله لجنوده هنا
حول قطاع غزه وكما ذكر الياس قبل قليل حتى
القوات الاسرائيليه غابت عن مناطق
دورياتها عن مناطق محيط قطاع غزه حتى لا
تكون هدفا للعمليات العسكريه اذا
عمليات الاستنفار الامني
ذهبت ابعد من ذلك حيث وجه الجيش
الاسرائيلي
بفتح الملاجئ في جنوب تل ابيب هنا كما
ذكرنا كذلك تم تحويل الطيران المدني من
مطار بنغوريون الدولي شرق التل ابيب الى
مسارات اقلاع وهبوط بديله اضافه الى ذلك
الى هذا كله طبعا رفع الجيش الاسرائيلي
درجه التاهب في شمال في المنظومات
الدفاعيه في شمال وجنوب
اسرائيل لكن السؤال يطرح هنا لماذا كل هذا
التاهب ما الذي تخشاه اسرائيل على هذه
الخارطه سنشرح مدى الصواريخ التي تملكها
الفصائل الفلسطينيه والتي يمكن ان تستهدف
عمق الداخل الاسرائيلي اللون الاول الذي
تشاهدونه هنا هذا الاحمر الغامق هو
للصواريخ قصيره المدى صواريخ القسام ايضا
اللون الثاني صواريخ القدس كما تشاهدون
وهي صواريخ مدى 10 الى 16 كلم وتملك
الفصائل الفلسطينيه مخزونا كبيرا منها
وعاده ما تستهدف استيروت ايضا هناك صواريخ
ذات مدى ابعد كصاروخ سجيل بمدى 55 كيلو
متر وبالتالي هذا الصاروخ مدينه كبئر
السبع هنا تقع هنا ضمن مدى استهدافه هناك
ايضا صاروخ ام 75 الذي قد تكون حاله
الاستنفار التي شاهدناها هذا اللون الازرق
كما تشاهدون ويصل هذه هي حدوده حاله
الاستنفار جنوب تل ابيب قد تكون مرتبطه
بهذا الصاروخ الذي يصل مداه الى تلك
المواقع بمدى 75 كيلومترا هناك صواريخ
الفجر بمدى 100 كلم هذه هي حدود مواقعها
ار 160 هذا اللون الاسود هنا تصل الى هذه
المنطقه وباللون البنفسجي باللون الاخضر
عفوا هنا صواريخ ام
322 ويمكن تصل هذه الصواريخ الى معظم
المناطق في داخل اسرائيل لا سيما يمكن ان
تصل الى هذه المدن الساحليه هنا التي
نراها والتي هي اكثر كثافه سكانيه ويمكن
ان تستهدف ايضا البنى التحتيه
للاسرائيليين في هذه المناطق حتى في
الشمال الاسرائيلي اذا بالعموم هذه
المنظومات من الصواريخ هي التي تملكها
الفصائل الفلسطينيه حاليا وهي التي ادت
الى رفع حاله التاهب الامني الكبيره التي
نراها في الداخل الاسرائيلي وفقا لما
تملكه
فصائل الفلسطينيه وتتوقع طبعا كما سمعنا
بعض وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تتوقع ان
تكون الهجمات في وسط وفي في الوسط هنا
جنوب تل ابيب وفي حدود غلاف قطاع غزه